peu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'impitoyable marche du progrès ne
s'arrête pas et quels que soient les
péripéties la proche banlieue de la
terre est d'ores et déjà à portée de ce
valeureux conquérant du monde qu'est
l'homme
à travers l'histoire qu'on racontait les
deux enfants de jeunes vignes et donc
voudrait faire croire qu'il existe dans
l'univers d intelligence supérieure à la
nôtre maison c'est ce qu'il faut penser
du pouvoir d'affabulations des enfants
sur toute une veille de noël
[Musique]
premier message visibilité paul planète
habitée premier naturel rencontre est
anormale il semble qu'il y ait sur cette
planète une grande variété de race le
nouvel a dit jay et de thym gigantesque
je n'attaque le géant quand une
enveloppe au pape qui en dissimule
l'essentiel ils semblent sortis d'une
immense ruche à multiples alvéoles en
fait le géant et que tu as gagné en
commun sa taille semble être celle du
plus grand nombre
je m'adapte d'eli lilly mans chose
étonnante les terriens semblent attachés
aux choses de dépasser
ils ont une fille soutirer 20 ans il se
sert long thier les uns contre les
autres ce qui semble indiquer un
entraîneur qui connaît les communautés à
moins qu'il ne s'agisse de leur moyen de
transport c'est à dire de l'an moyen de
reproduction
[Musique]
les terriens sont entre les canaux ce
tout semble posséder le plus de bien
elle a distribué le co2 pour que tout le
monde soit rassasié
et contre les terrienne sont des gens
m
ces gens se constatent régulièrement
mais on est là regardez toujours serrés
les uns contre les autres des films de
science fiction
bien fera chaque jour des enfants par
milliers meurent de faim victimes
innocentes des choses barbares des
adultes chacun de nous se doit tant
conscience de leur donner un morceau de
son gâteau de noël
sur cette planète singulière le bonheur
semble-t-il intimement liée à la
dilution
mais j'ai pu constater qu'il avait aussi
quelques rapports avec les sentiments
les terriens couleurs respectives dans
leur organisme pour eux les fêtes en
pleine nuit et la vente de merveilleuses
histoires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
je poursuis mon exploration région
élevée
[Musique]
dans ce territoire
formation une blanche est libre les
c'est la république
culte dollar
[Musique]
nouveaux territoires ici non
vous allez entendre des informations en
français les habitants tiennent à
rappeler anglais brume anglaise clariion
anglais l'homme souterrain signifie
aussi dans ce territoire différent
parallèle ina doit effectivement les
activités souterraines littérature
théâtre cinéma semble atteindre ici un
développement exceptionnel
elles sont le fait des intellectuels une
catégorie de terriens que l'on tient
certainement avec raison à l'essai dans
l'eau
l'état naturel qu'un lien commun demeure
ici encore le bonheur la musique qui
entre apparemment pour une large part
ces gens et re constate leur bonheur on
a regardé les films de fiction mais les
élections
[Musique]
l'ambiance de fête naturel terrienne
pendant ce pays des contrats sont tout à
fait surprenants
pas tant
je
m
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pu faire de nouvelles observations
sur l' enveloppe actes dont se
recouvrent le terrien il semble qu'elle
soit la source de plaisir tout à fait
inconnu chez nous tout est possible avec
les terriens dommage le regagne mon
premier lieu d'atterrissage
[Musique]
deux jeunes terriens se sont emparés de
mon vaisseau sos jeune bobby transe
alors
et
[Musique]